[Music]
my name is Jeremy Kent I want to
introduce you guys to someone special
tonight this is my fiancee Melissa go
ahead and stand up baby come on stand up
I know I'm taking I'm sorry earlier this
year we had some tough news some really
tough news can we do something special
for the most special person in my life
tonight you'll be brave for her
[Applause]
[Music]
hear her tonight now we have an artist
he's had 32 number-one singles four
point five million album sold
let's welcome Jeremy Kemp
I do believe you're getting married yeah
but we'll see get better I don't know
son you're only 20 years old you just
met this girl I'm supposed to be with
her
I can't explain it I just know that
Josie I want you to know that whatever
this is then wherever it takes us that
I'm with you every step every moment I'm
with you I'm so in
I would love you cherish you every
moment of every day only the love of
your life and your biggest fan
[Applause]
this was my destiny stop you were the
strong one not me all I have are
questions what am I supposed to do with
that
[Music]
I keep thinking
one person's life is changed by what I
go through
they'll help
I still believe
[Music]
you